it enables the Attorney General to
create a 2s
lgbtqi plus just for Giggles we
googled it it's an acronym for two
spirit well all right so first off
what's two Spirits does anyone here know
what two spirit is two spirit literally
like I'm actually not kidding at the
moment I honestly have no idea lesbian
we know what lesbians are everyone knows
what lesbians are you got your uh Rosie
O'Donnell's you got your Ellen DeGeneres
got your gaze okay we can figure that
out bisexuals they're just having a good
time you got your uh transgenders you
got your queer now what what is queer
that is separate from this like you're
if you're doing any of that other stuff
you're a little queer what's intersex
that means you have you got a wang and a
hoo-ha that's a lot I'll give those
people a pass I feel like that's a lot
on the plate you know what I mean then
you've got asexual which is like what
you want to have sex with cardboard or
something
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's April 6 2023 we're live streaming
on Rumble YouTube and locals I think
yesterday was our highest ever
concurrent viewers on our live show
across platforms so I want to thank you
growing group of Freedom Fighters and
Patriots I also want to thank Brock who
put together that short we put together
there that was just I mean
the transgender one the asexual one
absolutely perfect we have a tremendous
show for you I said to the guys I don't
do this often I usually ask them what do
you think we're going to get to today
and sometimes Daphne usually low
lowballs me to keep me on my toes she'll
do like a 9-2 Connor also usually a
little on the Lower Side Phoenix and
Brock are on the higher side we're
always going with the nine eight nine
nine nine I think we could get a 99
today I'm feeling so good about this
program we are about to give you the
direction of this thing also did the
Passover seder last night I'm feeling
focused knowing a little bit of history
and belief and the path that man is on
who yearns for Freedom which is some of
the stuff we often talk about here so uh
the the theme today is that we've got to
go on offense a little bit we have to go
on offense a bit more we're always
reacting right there's just a crazy set
of people and we constantly react to
them but going on offense as you have
seen here in Florida making that first
move it actually does give you an
advantage and it forces the left the the
progressives the globalists the
Socialists it forces them to defend
themselves and when you actually force
them to defend themselves they often
cannot because their ideas are so bad so
when you expose them for who they are
and what they are they're the machine
you can actually begin to pick up more
support on your side right like if you
actually stand up straight with your
shoulders back tell the world what you
believe and why you believe it and just
don't endlessly go on that dissent to
hell that they're always taking us on I
actually think he can change things for
the better that is the message that we
will be promoting today before we get to
it let me talk to you guys about my
Patriot Supply guys anyone who thinks
they won't need emergency food isn't
paying attention every day the headlines
get worse and worse is the unthinkable
next it pays to prepare which is why I
recommend you stock up on emergency food
right away you never know when the next
shoe will drop and when it does emerge
emergency food will be hard to find so
get yours now while it's on sale go to
mypatriotsupply.com and check out their
popular three-month emergency food kit
right now you'll save 200 bucks per kit
each kit gives you a wide variety of
delicious breakfasts lunches dinners
drinks and snacks providing over 2 000
calories a day for Optimum strength and
energy act now and claim your 200
savings per kit you'll sleep better
knowing your family won't suffer if the
worst ever happens go to
mypatriotsupply.com and you'll enjoy
free shipping too that's my Patriot
supply.com and now back to me okay so
let's talk about going on the offense
when it comes to this culture War and
what fruits you can reap when you do
well just yesterday this beautiful thing
happened it's not often that beautiful
things happen on Twitter it's gotten a
significantly better obviously since
Elon Musk has taken over but it's
usually just a cesspool with insanity
but check this out yesterday
NPR is now labeled U.S state Affiliated
media now of course NPR does get
donations from people that is true it
also gets they claim it's one percent of
their budget from the federal government
it's a little unclear to me what that
number actually is but we know they get
some money from the government and we
know that NPR anyone knows this this is
not partisan to say NPR obviously is a
partisan Outlet right they're obviously
always in lockstep with the Democrats
with the progressives with the left they
are always going after scary Republicans
and conservatives Etc et cetera so Elon
Musk in his quest to democratize Twitter
to make it so that corporate press
does not deserve nor will get any more
credit
then the average independent journalist
who's doing the best he can to get to
something roughly approximate to truth
Elon is taken away that uh that special
that special status that they had as not
state-affiliated media when they
actually are Elon tweeted this in
response to Benny Johnson who had
noticed it and tweeted out uh he wrote
seems accurate and here is the uh the
Twitter help center definition of
state-affiliated media State Affiliated
media is defined as Outlets where the
state exercises control over editorial
content through financial resources
direct or indirect political pressures
and or control over production and
distribution according to Twitter's help
center so look when I say that it's not
partisan to say that NPR obviously was a
wing of the Democrat Party or that
they're always pushing Progressive
messaging it's obvious is what side of
the culture where they're on it's
obvious what side of the the political
divide they're on we could have given
you we could have spent literally I
could have sat in this room all day long
just reading NPR headlines that lean
left that lie about the right we just
picked a couple here that we thought
were sort of seminal uh ones let's just
go through them one at a time uh here's
one uh well let's just go Russian
military intelligence the gru is linked
to the invasion of Ukraine and
interference in the 2016 U.S
presidential election now it's suspected
of a bounty program to kill U.S troops
in Afghanistan that was in 2020 turned
out completely untrue but of course what
were they trying to do there they were
trying to scare you uh because Donald
Trump had become president in 2016. uh
let's pick another one here all the way
to the right some scientists this is
about a year and a half ago no yeah no
this is two years ago now some
scientists have welcomed President
Biden's directive to further scrutinize
the lab League Theory I think it opens
the door for other scientists to weigh
in without being called conspiracy
theorists Hot Diggity Dog turned out to
be true what else NPR politics NRA and
new document acknowledges more than 20
Russian linked contributors yes the NRA
is controlled by the Russians it just
never ends uh NPR did put out a
statement after being labeled
state-affiliated media they said we were
Disturbed to see last night that Twitter
has labeled NPR a state-affiliated media
a description that per Twitter's own
guidelines does not apply to NPR NPR and
our member stations are supported by
millions of listeners who depend on us
for independent fact-based journalism we
provide I'm cracking up as I'm saying
this NPR stands for freedom of speech
and holding the powerful accountable it
is unacceptable for Twitter to label us
this way a vigorous Free Press is
essential to the health of our democracy
uh Phoenix do a little work while we're
doing this show or one of you guys over
there scan through all of NPR's tweets
as far back as you can imagine find me
all the tweets where they were calling
to open up the states and going against
mandates find me all the tweets where
they were trying to go against the
narrative on the Ukraine war find me all
the tweets where they were saying maybe
Brett Kavanaugh shouldn't be treated as
a serial rapist you're going to have a
lot of work to do while I'm doing this
uh also beautifully I mean it's it's
happening right in front of our eyes if
you let the good stuff in it really is
happening right now another little
moment and I know Twitter is not real
life but what happens on Twitter leaks
into the real world it's just a
precursor
for the reality of Tomorrow the other
thing is that Elon Musk is taking away
the blue checks unless you pay for it so
what happened in the last you know 10 or
12 years of Twitter is that if you were
politically connected for the most part
or you were a big Hollywood person and
you had a big agency behind you you
could get that blue check and if you got
that blue check you somehow you somehow
seem more legit to people it was really
originally just to verify people and
there was a value in that right if you
have a well-known person they're going
to be impersonated a gajillion times
over you the blue check signified you
are that person but what it came to be
was a status symbol and then suddenly
all of these quote-unquote journalists
who worked at trash Outlets like The
Daily Beast and huffpo and BuzzFeed and
the rest they all got these blue checks
and it made it seem somehow like they
were legit and the average guy who's out
on the streets with his camera trying to
really figure things out that he's not
legit so Elon as of like like three days
ago has decided no more if you want the
blue check you got to pay for it and no
one is going to get it just because they
are who they are uh here's a tweet from
The New York Times which no longer has
the blue check as you can see Twitter on
Tuesday added a label to NPR's account
designating the broadcaster U.S state
Affiliated media other news media
Twitter accounts with the label include
RT of Russia which is state-sponsored
media and xinhua of China NPR denounced
the move as unacceptable so of course
New York Times which no longer has its
blue check it could pay I think it's 8
or 10 maybe 12 a month but they're just
not willing to do it so all of the the
New York Times journalists that had the
blue check that made it seem like they
were journalists they no longer have it
unless they're willing to pay out of
their pocket I paid I paid mine was
going to go away I got one years ago
however I got it right I actually
somehow met somebody that knew somebody
at Twitter that's how I got mine I was
verified they were going to take it away
I feel that it is worth the eight or ten
dollars so that people will know if Dave
Rubin tweet something there's a check
next to my name and it is what it is but
here look they it's gone it's gone
that's it New York Times no longer has
the blue check and I certainly hope this
does lead to their continued dissent
into Oblivion that they should not be
thought of as a more authoritarian on
any issue than anyone else the New York
Times much like NPR much like CNN and
Washington Post and MSNBC and the rest
of them they have lied about almost
everything they have faked their
credibility right we have fancy logos we
have big budgets we get you know big
corporations to put commercials on our
content but they lie about pretty much
everything now you might be going Dave
I'm not on Twitter I don't really care
about this minutia why does this matter
to me well as I said
it's a it's an airlock right what
happens on Twitter you might think it
just stays there but it does eventually
leak out into the real world much like I
always say that the truth has become a
Time release pill we know a certain set
of people know things are true or
suspect things are true and it's only
months and years later that we actually
find that out so why does it matter I
will tell you in just a second but first
ladies and gentlemen I want to talk to
you about my white box did you know I
know you know because you watched this
show 60 of us poor production comes from
one company owned by the Chinese and
their Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day well
there's a better way folks I'd like to
tell you about moink that's moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat in every box
like Ribeyes chicken breast pork chops
salmon fillets and much more plus you
can cancel any time there's nothing
better than cooking their meats on my
big green egg on a Friday afternoon
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted plus they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got moaked
keep American farming going by signing
up at moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste
m-o-i-n-k box.com slash
reubenwinkbox.com Reuben and now back to
me so why does this matter
the idea that the mainstream media is
not only are more and more people every
day waking up to their nonsense right
you you watching this I get it okay so
you're watching this you've been read
billed to a degree but how many people
do you know that are starting to
question things right it is starting to
happen the hysterical leftists of five
years ago yeah a lot of them are more
hysterical but a certain amount of them
are waking up we're seeing it happen
people are going the media has lied
about this and that this this sham Trump
indictment even
not the crazy left this I get it they're
in on it they they want it to happen no
matter what they don't care about
equality under the law or any of those
things but the certain average person
who may be somewhat apolitical is kind
of going well you know we did try the
two impeachments on the guy in the
Mar-A-Lago raid and the Russia collusion
and yada yada yada maybe this is a bit
much okay so the fact that these people
are losing momentum is
absolutely good now I want to show you
something that's been making the rounds
on the Twitter this is a video uh
Patrick Bet David who I'm doing his live
podcast tonight in Fort Lauderdale uh
this evening with mayor Rudy Giuliani
actually
um he tweeted this out but it's been
making the Rounds Around the internet
and check this out this is a I believe
it's a college professor I think it's a
college professor it might be high
school teacher but I think it's a
college professor uh and watch how he
lays out so beautifully what propaganda
over time does to you does to the people
around you it does to Society at Large
despite what you might be thinking these
two circles are not equal I repeat these
two circles are not equal one is in fact
larger than the other what I need you to
do is determine which one that is
so please raise your hand if you believe
the blue circle is larger than the red
all right please raise your hand if you
believe the red circle is larger than
the blue
all right very good now before I said
anything about these two circles what
was your first instinct
equal right because they look equal the
reason why they look equal is because in
fact they are equal these two circles
are identical yet I got just about every
one of you to raise your hand and say
that they're not so what do we learn
that you can be manipulated like that to
believe in something that goes against
your Natural Instincts just just imagine
just imagine as a child you're taught
that the blue circle is larger than the
red if you say it enough times you
convince yourself that's the truth
if you're told to lie enough times it
becomes part of your reality and if
enough people are taught that lie that
the blue circle is larger than the red
well now it becomes part of the culture
and if that culture then passes that
misinformation along to the Next
Generation Well now it becomes tradition
isn't that interesting you take a group
of people sitting in a room hey make a
decision about this thing
they're going to get it wrong they're
just going to have their own biases and
over time over Generations you can get a
whole bunch of people to believe a whole
bunch of as an old elderly man that I
know says is malarkey
that's what you can do and the
mainstream media has been doing this to
us for a really really long time it's
why so many people are crazy it's why
people don't know the difference between
boys and girls it's why so many people
have or had or it's recurring again now
Trump derangement syndrome because
people's reality is so out of whack with
what they are seeing on the media the
media has lied for so long
but now Independent Media is here
rumble's here I'm here plenty of other
people are here and we're breaking
through the nonsense it's going to be a
lot of work we're just at the beginning
we're always right back at the beginning
but you can see I just thought that was
perfect and that's why it was it was
going viral the way it was it was like
man that is what's happening to us in
real time now let's show you some
real-time versions of that right now uh
as you know Donald Trump was arraigned
in New York City and then two nights ago
he went back to Florida he went to
Mar-A-Lago and he gave a speech and most
of the networks were covering it here's
how Rachel Maddow on MSNBC The televised
mental institution known as MSNBC here's
how she chose to cover it
is making remarks tonight um from his
home in Florida as far as we can tell
and what we're prepared for here is that
this is basically a campaign speech in
which he is repeating his same lies and
allegations against his perceived
enemies it is just getting started
um so far he's just giving his normal
list of grievances we don't consider
that necessarily newsworthy and there's
a cost to us as a news organization of
knowingly broadcasting untrue things so
our deal with you is that we will
monitor these remarks if he does say
anything newsworthy we will turn them
around and report on that right away but
for now just know that it's happening
and we're not taking it wow Rachel
you're such a journalist you're such a
journalist you won't broadcast untrue
things Hot Diggity Dog where'd we find
this
it means that instead of the vaccine
being able excuse me it means for
instead of the virus being able to hop
from person to person to person to
person spreading and spreading sickening
some of them but not all of them and the
ones that it doesn't stick and don't
know they have it and then they give to
even more people because they didn't
recognize they were
right instead of the virus being able to
hop from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way now we know that the vaccines work
well enough that the virus stops with
every vaccinated person
a vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else
cannot use a vaccinated person as a host
to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this
okay so everything she said right there
was untrue now you might be going but
Dave she didn't knowingly lie about that
stuff except the problem is she
knowingly swallowed the propaganda that
Pfizer and moderna and the NIH and the
CDC and fauci and everybody else were
putting out there that's not the job of
a journalist that's the job of a public
relations executive and that's what she
acts as while she is on once again the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC Glenn Greenwald who's an actual
journalist an independent journalist who
I actually have some political
disagreements with he watched that clip
of Maddow talking about Trump and he
tweeted this out I thought this was just
perfect he wrote the person talking
about Maddow who won a 30 million dollar
a year Comcast contract by telling
liberals Biden laptop was rushing
disinformation lab leak was debunked
Trump had secret server with Alpha a
bank Russia put bonus bounties on U.S
soldiers says she's too worried about
the lies to show Trump's speech so you
get it guys you get it you see why I
showed you that viral video of the two
circles and how over time people swallow
the lies more and more and then when
they are confronted with truth they have
to make a choice will I go down the
scary Red pilled Road where I will see
the world as it is not as I as I wish it
to be and it's going to be scary and I
may have to acknowledge that I actually
got a whole bunch of stuff wrong and I
said awful things about other people and
I really screwed up a whole bunch of
stuff or will I just continue that blue
pilled slumber
I would argue if you're watching the
televised mental institution as known as
MSNBC unironically you've made your
choice
um but uh we thought there's got to be a
compilation of the media lying about
everything and it's got well there's
many of them could we find one and then
we were like yeah we can't here
we are watching Republicans not just
destroying democracy in the dark
breaking into election officers and
plugging stuff in we're watching them do
it from rally stages debate stages we
could lose our democracy and it could
happen in 17 days a majority of
Americans believe that democracy is
under threat democracy on the ballot
it's not just a slogan a lot of
Republicans in the last three weeks have
suddenly found themselves deciding hey
party over country I'm wondering whether
this puts America into the fast lane
towards illiberal democracy well I'm not
going to say that you know the GOP or
Nazis at this point or whatever but it
certainly sounds very familiar we will
wake up the morning after election day
we might not even call it that anymore
in two years the future is not
Republican party so they have to cheat
do you think it's time to ask for
friends and allies to come over and help
us monitor our elections do you think it
requires you know a democracy commission
the Republicans have an explicit
incentive to make the economy work they
will cut Social Security they're going
to cut lunches for children if
Republicans win control of one or both
house of Congress they will do
everything in their power to sabotage
the economy they are not going to help
you so why would you vote for them that
that light at the end that's the best
one like there's so much laughably
ridiculous stuff they're they're not
gonna help you so why would you vote for
them that gets to the mentality of these
people they think the government is
supposed to help you the government is
not supposed to help you Ronald Reagan
the nine scariest words in the English
language are I'm here from the
government and I'm here to help I'm from
the government and I'm here to help
those are the scariest words because the
government screws up absolutely
everything but these people it's not
just that they lie that these are
propagandists who lie about everything
it's that they it would be one thing if
they just lied about like what the
little policy differences are but they
are lying to keep people in an endless
state of Hysteria do I make mistakes on
this show on the show for sure do I have
my own biases for sure do I hide that no
uh but do you think when you're tuning
into this or do you when this show ends
like I hope you laugh a little bit you
got a little bit entertained you learned
a little something something like that
but I don't send you off into the world
completely Bamboozled by the truth like
I whacked you in the head you got
cartoon Stars flying around your head
and then you're just angry at everybody
what we try to do is Expose and debunk
the nonsense here what they are doing is
trying to keep a certain amount of
people so afraid of their own shadow
that they will vote their own rights
away and this is a major major problem
because although they are losing Steam
and NPR is now labeled state-affiliated
media and the New York Times doesn't
have their blue check and the ratings
for all of those things
are failing and as I said we had our
biggest concurrent live stream uh
yesterday ever beat basically every CNN
and MSNBC show I'm sure it beat all of
them actually we probably didn't be
Tucker last night I'll I'll take Tucker
that'll be pretty good and several other
Fox shows that are crushing it but the
point is they are lying and keeping
everyone in a Perpetual state of
insanity and then you wonder why the
culture is the way it is and it has
something to do with the people that are
supposed to be the taste makers of
culture so their negligence and their
malice is exactly what has led this
country to the state that it is in today
when we'd be having this Banana Republic
nonsense like hauling in a former
president to a New York City courtroom
on charges that are from years ago and
everyone knows wouldn't be happening if
he wasn't running for president again
do we have any video about the
mainstream media lying about Trump we
were able to come up with some how do we
do that that's incredible we are working
our butts off over here
does the public understand just how much
trouble the president is in to believe
that the president isn't compromised
requires such a leap of faith I think we
have all the proof we need of a scandal
that's uh arguably worse than Watergate
the U.S president possibly working for
the Russians possibly an unwitting Pawn
here's what the president said when
asked if he was a secret Russian agent
the president did not directly answer
the question why not just say no if
that's the answer there is tons of proof
of potential collusion we have dramatic
evidence of collusion how is it not
collusion how is all of that not
solution a political hurricane is out
there it sees for him we'll call it
hurricane Vladimir if you will Donald
Trump knows the news is tightening the
Noose is tightening the Noose is
tightening if you will The Noose is
tightening around the president The
Noose is tightening and I think they're
shocked that the Noose is tightening the
people might go to jail he knows he and
POTUS are going to prison well I think
they're all going to end up together in
prison and maybe that's a oh my God
the walls appear to be closing in on the
president
you know Connor said to me in the middle
of that like totally straightfaced I
miss stelter I think we all kind of Miss
stealth her in a way who would have
thunk we all miss Brian stelter who now
because irony is dead is a teacher of
Journalism at Harvard University the
best line on that man I mean there's
there's so much and you got to remember
they lost every The Noose should have
had a noose in here I could use a noose
for some of these shows like the best
line on that though was Chris Cuomo when
he says there are there is tons of proof
of potential collusion it's like the
language itself these people are insane
so they led us to this they they created
a situation where a bunch of hysterical
lunatics some who then got voted into
Congress and the Senate as Democrats and
then became DA's in places like New York
thought that they were stopping orange
Hitler so you would drag us all to your
Banana Republic nonsense to do anything
you could to stop him the coverage of
trump over the years and it was a it was
a double-edged sword right they hated
Trump but they needed him right because
the second Trump went out of office for
these last two years there ratings
tanked now their ratings are going up
again the media is on the same side As
Trump you got it you really need to
understand that people say Trump's the
one fighting the machine but he is now
firm he is fighting the political
machine to an extent obviously right
I accept that he is fighting the Deep
State sure but he is also now part of
the media machine and he even was before
he was president he was the number one
host on television for a reality
television show The Apprentice and the
Celebrity Apprentice that was the number
one reality show out there but now he's
there there is a match made in heaven
right there is a Faustian bargain
between the media and Trump they need
each other and that is why they will
keep scaring the hell out of you over
Trump and I think there's another reason
which is what Joy Behar said the other
day which we showed you which is that
Trump can't win he can't bring in new
voters so they want Trump to be the
Republican nominee but the coverage over
the last couple years has led our
country to this moment this moment where
we recklessly dangerously arrest former
presidents so here's the image again
this is Trump at the courthouse on
Tuesday this was uh right as the officer
before him didn't hold the door open
just let the door slam on him which you
know that was planned and uh now we're
going to show you something from The
View can we pull up the uh warning there
there we go uh and you for a second
you're going to freak out when you see
this clip because for just a second
Alyssa Farah who is the quote-unquote
conservative on the show but she's a pet
conservative they give her they tap
around the head and give her a cookie at
the end and you know they'll all throw
her under the bus once she gets fired
and I do hope it's worth the 200 Grand a
year for three years or whatever she's
getting on it um to sell your soul you
know you probably should have negotiated
more when you're selling your soul you
get better better agent but anyway uh
she's gonna make sense for a second
Alyssa fair is going to kind of make
sense for a second and then Sunny Hosten
talks so you'll figure out the rest
quick though two things can be true at
once yesterday was a bad day for Donald
Trump the first indicted former
president I want to see this guy held
accountable this case is not taking
Donald Trump down and I say that for a
couple years how do you know that there
was well just real quick there was no
conspiracy charge which a lot of folks
were looking to see yeah
the felony charges the the max sentence
is four years but this is a first time
offender it's a non-violent crime it's a
classy felony every legal expert I've
talked to has said most likely a fine in
probation if he's even tell you what
you're wrong is this legal expert
I will tell you why you're wrong
prosecutors are not only in the business
of Prosecuting crimes we're in the
business of sending out a message if you
let the president of the United States
be found guilty of one to 34 counts even
if they're misdemeanors and he gets to
go home scot-free you're sending them
that's not free we're just saying it's
going to be a fine and probation
all right first off just Sonny hosten's
General tone and that's what I'm saying
Alyssa you think they like you now and
you know they don't really like you like
they're just using you but the way that
Sunny Hosten talks down to people like
literally with her nose up down to
people she's so profoundly unpleasant
but okay let that be what's interesting
is she's saying that you should
prosecute to send a message now that's
interesting because now I would say and
I think most people who believe in
equaling under the law believe that you
should be prosecuting based on the laws
that are on the books so if you I don't
know let's say murder somebody everyone
who murders somebody should be treated
equally under the law and you should
have to prove that they did it they have
a chance to prove that they are not
guilty and that's how it should work but
you should prosecute to send a message
it took us literally point zero zero two
seconds to find this from The New Yorker
on Alvin Bragg's third day as Manhattan
district attorney in January 2021. he
stated that his office would no longer
prosecute low-level offenses such as
subway fare evasion resistance to arrest
or prostitution unless they were part of
an accompanying felony charge so if you
were sending a message if that's what
prosecution is about then this guy has
said to New Yorkers jump the turnstiles
be prostitutes uh resist arrest I mean
the idea that resisting arrest would be
something that wouldn't get you in
trouble is absolutely insane so well I
guess if you're a prostitute and they
are about to arrest you and now you can
not only not get arrested for
prostitution but you can also basically
smack the cop in the face so what was
the message that Alvin Bragg has been
sending to New Yorkers it was break the
law
it was break the law so what is the one
thing that the mainstream media that
these the corporate press that these
people never do what they never do is
pursue the truth they never go after the
people who deserve to be looked at right
who really are the ones who are riling
up people and making everybody angry and
lying about everything and all of that
stuff for example the squad right you've
got your aocs and your ilhan Omars and
your Rashida talibs a group of people
who are here to destroy America they are
socialists they do not like our system
they do not like our founding
um they are they are clearly here to to
ferment to foment anti-American
sentiment check out this tweet by
Rashida Talib this was two days ago I
wanted to cover yesterday we couldn't
get to it uh every day 120 Americans are
killed by gun violence there have been
18 school shootings so far this year
every single day that Republicans
prioritize big Tree in Banning books and
drag shows more Americans will die I
mean she is just man she could get my
Sunny Hostin award for being the worst
person on the show today that should be
the official award we'll have a little
clay Sunny Hosten and we'll mail it to
these people
um she's conflating issues right the the
drag queen Story Hour and these
ridiculous pornography books that are in
schools have nothing to do with school
shootings also taking away guns from
people who are abiding by the law is not
going to stop the bad people we played
the video of it last week or when I sat
down with Ted Cruz in DC he tried to get
an armed guard at every school entrance
in the United States every single
Democrat voted against it Dan Crenshaw
had a very similar policy that he was
trying to get forth but they're focused
on these books this seems to be a
reoccurring thing with these people that
the Republicans are Banning books and
that especially Florida were Banning
books Connor can we put up the image of
genderqueer now this is gender queer
this is the book that everyone's talking
about so just to be very very clear here
in Florida
they are not Banning books what they are
doing right now is that the local school
districts are doing reviews of books
just to see what's on the shelves and
each School District can make their
choice as to what they are going to have
in there which of course makes sense
parents and Educators can come together
and discuss what is age-appropriate for
students now this is the only book this
gender queer book is the only book that
has been banned so far now what's
fascinating about this book is we blurt
out some images because we're a family
show here but we did see the images
before we blurred them out and I really
want to get this correct so I've got
everybody on the team I need you all
focused right now what we are blurring
out there is that there is a girl we
believe it is a girl
who does not have a penis because
generally speaking girls do not have
penises who's using a dildo
and then has her
what we think is asexual friend
performing oral sex on the dildo so she
can pretend she's a boy that's what we
are blurring out for you that is what
Rashida Talib and Gavin Newsom and the
lunatics at the view and all of these
people think should be in public schools
for kids to learn about
am I am I just old-fashioned
how about good night Moon
like what
put it up one more just one more time we
blurted out we had but did I get that
right so just one more time guys it's a
chick using a dildo to have what we
think is her male or at least the the
male was identifying as using weird
pronouns to perform more
all right forget it forget it you got
the point you got the point here's a
drag queen in Canada go
we will not let fear win
a world without trans people has never
existed a world without drag has never
existed and it never will Queen people
have always been here amongst us they
are our co-workers they are our brothers
our sisters they're our mothers our
fathers they're our families dragon's
art dragon's culture drug is educational
Drake is creative Drake is comedy but
drag is not a crime
my name is Scarlet Bobo and thank you so
much for your time if you live in Canada
get out get out a few of you can come
here to Florida but we're closing this
thing down pretty soon trust me I've got
the governors here we're putting up a
wall Gators the whole freaking thing
do you see what they do with everything
though so that was at that ridiculous
press conference yesterday where the
two-spirited woman was trying to yeah
okay fine you got it but what she's
saying is that the world has never
existed without queer people or trans
people okay nobody's saying that what
we're saying is this should not be
in front of kids would that just be okay
with you guys wear your crazy uh wig put
on your God forsaken makeup whatever you
want to do with your life fine but why
must you dance in front of children
unless you dance in front of trump
choking as I'm saying it why would you
dance why must you dance in front of
children for money
why must you do that again why do you
not go to the annual actuary conference
why do they only do it at late night
clubs where adults are getting drunk and
trying to hook up with each other and
then they do it for children there seems
to be nothing in between on that right
why is that can someone explain that to
me anyway when you realize that this
stuff has leaked up all the way because
what happens is you get these radical
activists with these crazy ideas and
they're a tiny minority and everyone
knows it's nonsense but nobody wants to
be the guy being like you people stop
doing that nobody wants to be that guy
waving the finger we need more of those
people some people have tried it uh a
whole bunch of us have tried it I would
say but no I get it the average person
doesn't want to be that person like you
want to be accepting and tolerant nice
and diversity is our strength and all
that stuff but what happens is these
radical activists push all of this
insane nonsense so literally at Public
Schools they've got a book where a girl
is having oral sex performed on a dildo
and that's thought of as as tolerable
for children
and then
and then you have the mainstream media
which runs cover for it because they
never acknowledge what's in the content
of the books that are being banned they
just say Republicans are mean and
banning books and you might go well all
right well it's just books who cares all
right but it's also now that they are
pushing sex change surgeries not gender
affirming care don't use their language
it is not affirming to Lop off
somebody's Wang all right it's not
I was going to say Google it but don't
Google that
here is Corinne Jean-Pierre our White
House Press Secretary saying that minor
sex change surgeries are between a
parent and a child and government should
stay out now it's ironic that they've
suddenly become libertarian on this
we'll get some more on that in a second
and then today Indiana just uh banned
puberty blockers hormone therapies and
gender transition surgeries for minors
I'm wondering what the president's
reaction is to the Indiana Governor
signing that bill into law and does the
president have a position on at what age
these kinds of therapies and surgeries
are appropriate that's something for a
child and and their parents to decide
it's not something we believe should be
decided by uh by legislators so I'll
leave it there it is absolutely
incredible the hypocrisy with these
people I know hypocrisy is dead but
their hypocrisy is incredible the same
people who will be upset if a parent
comes to a school board meeting saying I
don't want drag queens dancing in front
of my children they're the same ones
that say it's up to a parent and a child
to decide if they should have their nuts
chopped off you see the irony of this
right like if a parent objects to a book
or objects to a drag queen then the
parent is completely out of control in
their far-right Maniac if as long as the
parent is 4 the genitals being chopped
off then it should be between a parent
and a child these people want the
government to be involved in absolutely
everything suddenly when some red states
are saying you know maybe government
does have a little bit of a role to have
something to do with a functioning state
maybe we should be protecting children
it's something like that and now they're
upset about that but suddenly they're
all Libertarians they're all libertarian
it's absolutely incredible by the way
cringe John Pierre cringe that's right
cringe I wish you were a Libertarian I
wish you would get the hell out of my
life I wish Joe Biden had nothing to do
with my life or any of you people you're
right stay out of our Lives most things
should be done between a parent and a
child how about you give us our tax
money back that you steal for your crazy
Wars and everything else how about you
just stay out of our Lives all together
and we'll make decisions for ourselves
but you guys are pushing this stuff on
us constantly and it's not just that
they're pushing all of the gender stuff
and the race stuff and that they lied
about covet and everything else it's
that there is also an
unbelievable amount of crime happening
in blue cities right now you know it we
cover it all the time by the way in
Chicago you know remember a couple weeks
ago they voted out that lunatic
Beetlejuice over there Lori Lightfoot
well it turns out that they have since
voted in probably even more of a far
left Progressive so Chicago is just
going to keep getting worse but the
worst of the the worst as you guys know
is San Francisco San Francisco has
completely collapsed it is not a
coincidence that San Francisco was once
run by at the time mayor Gavin Newsom
now governor of California Gavin Newsom
there was a horrific murder on the
streets of California of San Francisco
about two days ago no I think it was
this weekend so it was about three days
ago uh cash app founder probably I think
is 43 years old was stabbed to death in
San Francisco here's CBS covering what
happened
tonight friends and family are
confirming what many fear the 43 year
old man San Francisco police found
stabbed here on Main Street early
Tuesday morning is well-known Tech
executive Bob Lee the father of two was
Chief product officer at cryptocurrency
startup mobile coin before that he
worked with former Twitter CEO Jack
Dorsey at Square Dorsey today called his
death heartbreaking Lee would later
create the mobile payment service cash
app burnt Twitter CEO Elon Musk
responded to news of the killing by
taking a swipe at the city violent crime
in SF he said is horrific
okay it's an unbelievable murder look
the guy 43 years old what's interesting
about this uh is that well Jack Dorsey
from Twitter comments about it but Jack
Dorsey was one of the main people at
Twitter there who was pumping money into
the things and defending all of the
horrific ideas that have destroyed what
once was a great City San Francisco and
I went to it for the first time about 15
years ago was was absolutely beautiful
gorgeous thriving flourishing and now it
is just everything the reverse of that
uh Elon musk's comments are completely
right the amount of security he has to
have at the Twitter offices which is in
the midst of a zombie apocalypse and
what's interesting about this story
particularly is that this this poor guy
he had fled San Francisco yeah he used
to live in San Francisco you know where
he lived now Miami he had moved to
Florida to enjoy some Freedom he was
back there uh doing some business and
and he got murdered on the streets and I
have to tell you when I was there you
know when I was there meeting Elon a
couple what was that two months ago or
so it is the first first time in my life
in an American city that I was ever
afraid for uh for my own safety we have
the video we have the video remember
this video that I took this is literally
right outside the Twitter offices so you
must understand you have the world's
richest man upstairs and here is video
of me walking around this is one block
away from Twitter offices and this was
sprawling across the entire city drugs
Mayhem zombies enjoy
why aren't the ladies of the view who
are so compassionate and care about
people remember Joy Behar the
Republicans don't care about you well
the implication is that we Democrats do
so why is it that Democrat cities look
like that if you can find republican-led
cities that look like that please send
me the video and I will show it and I
will go after the Republican mayor in
those cities that's doing it but it's
Denver that looks like that that was a
real shocker for me when I went on tour
in Denver it is Los Angeles it is San
Francisco it is Portland in Seattle Okay
blah blah blah it's Austin you got it
you got it Democrats do not care about
other people Democrats care about power
that's what these media people care
about that's what the politicians care
about and that's why people are fleeing
blue cities and fleeing blue States and
coming to places where there is Law and
Order and where there are flourishing
economies because we don't put policies
in place that destroy economies which
ultimately destroy families destroy
communities destroy schools
etc
etc you might be thinking now Dave wait
a minute you said this show is a nine
nine but I'm feeling a little depressed
it's a little depressing hearing
mainstream media lies it's a little
depressing uh hearing about this murder
it's a little depressing watching the
general Mayhem of the blue cities well I
got a good one for you because we're
going to bring it home on a positive
note this is fantastic this is just
yesterday
Democrat congresswoman named Tricia
cotham from North Carolina
she's no longer a Democrat she's moving
over to the Gob
modern day Democratic party has become
unrecognizable to me
and to so many others throughout this
state and this country
the party wants to villainize anyone who
has free thought
free judgment has Solutions who wants to
get to work to better our state not just
sit in a meeting and have a workshop
after a workshop but really work with
individuals to get things done because
that's what real public servants do
if you don't do exactly what the
Democrats want you to do they will try
to bully you they will try to cast you
aside I got to tell you guys uh watching
that is so affirming for me personally
because what she says there about free
thought and what they will do for you to
you and and when you step away and all
that stuff literally you've all seen it
I'm sure my why I left the left video I
did on Prager you seven years ago that's
what I was saying and now that is you
know that time release pill truth is
Time released people more and more
people are realizing it what's
interesting about this also Phoenix just
told me that her switching from Democrat
to GOP now gives the Republicans a super
majority in North Carolina so watch
watch what happens now in North Carolina
I bet you it will become more stable it
will become safer they will protect kids
they will not allow for this woke
nonsense and everything else so this is
this is a really really nice moment but
guys the media's lies their malice their
negligence it presents us with an
opportunity to pick up those disaffected
liberals the the people that have been
bamboozled and everything else and we
just need more and more people to see it
so I want to end with this tweet from
Elon Musk this is in July of 2022 he
said the media is a click seeking
machine dressed up as a truth seeking
machine
yes yes it is
we must keep going we will get to that
Promised Land there's a little a little
Passover messaging for you right you got
to leave the oppression leave the
oppression of Egypt you may have to
wander in the desert for 40 years we
might be maybe we're in year 36 of 40
right now we've been wandering confused
looking for a leader trying to figure
out what what does the promised land
look like well you know what you also
have to map what the promised land will
be right the Hebrews didn't just show up
to the promised land and magically
create an incredible Society you have to
really be thinking what would our
society look like
Florida blueprint we have everything we
need guys and now we got to start
putting it together and I really really
do believe that we can uh ladies and
gentlemen my full interview with Senator
Ron Johnson from Wisconsin uh is up
right now across platforms we're going
to do a post-game show in just a moment
if you have not joined us in locals you
know we got a great community of people
in there talking about these ideas
questioning things going back and forth
some people are more on the Trump side
people some people are more on the
DeSantis side it's a wide swath of
people I'm happy that everybody's there
and I love communicating with you guys
and having drinks with you like we did
in DC last week so we'll do a post game
show in just a couple seconds if you
want to join us reubenreport.locals.com
we leave you
with the elderly man pretending to be
president making a classic mistake and
I'll see everyone else in 37 seconds
town of Rolling Stone will be back
and we'll be with you every step of the
way and I that I what did I say I I
didn't I said Rolling Fork Rolling Stone
I got my mind going here
[Music]
oh